[Música]
un momento de alegría después de la
catástrofe un grupo de voluntarios se
acercó un asentamiento de tiendas de
campaña en la provincia de hatay para
acompañar a los niños que han
sobrevivido al terremoto y ayudarlos a
liberar los traumas
Nuestro objetivo principal es mantener
la solidaridad han sido gravemente
traumatizados consecutiva y
repetidamente ha habido grandes pérdidas
después de que las personas
experimentasen dolor y pérdidas de esta
escala la primera forma de llegar a
ellos a nivel psicológico es
solidarizarse con ellos y mostrarles que
otra persona también puede ver su dolor
varios miembros de este personal
formaron parte de los trabajos de
búsqueda y rescate de las últimas
semanas y con esas operaciones
concluidas ahora enfocaron su atención
en los niños afectados
curamos muchas heridas pero el trabajo
de búsqueda y rescate se detuvo y ahora
se están limpiando los escombros por lo
tanto con mi propio equipo somos
voluntarios para niños
La mejor parte de nuestro trabajo es
ayudar a estos niños a superar su trauma
por eso estamos aquí nos quedamos con
ellos en esta ciudad de tiendas de
campaña
tocando la guitarra cantando y jugando
los voluntarios acompañan a los jóvenes
de los campamentos a afrontar la
situación una gran cantidad de niños
quedaron sin hogar por el terremoto en
el sur Turco según cifras arrojadas por
unicef más de 7 millones de menores se
vieron perjudicados por las
consecuencias del sismo del pasado 6 de
febrero en Turquía y Siria que miles
más hayan muertos